the jurogan experience there is some
very strange water experiments you can
do with frequencies and oh wow you can
set it down on
plates and make some really cool stuff
too it all shapes look at that so the
electricity running into the water makes
it through that spiral sound really it's
not even like a sign
sound vibrations like it's
this is the spout the spout is connected
to a speaker the speaker is being
controlled by an oscillation
but if you do all the hurt you can see
it oh my god this is incredible what is
the uh
there are this is just one experiment
for this there's a lot of other really
really cool ones there's the ones that
run through all the frequencies and you
have these uh
the balance frequencies which is
i'm messing up the frequencies right now
i can't remember tvi i just blame it on
tbi
having smoke another joint
the uh
it changes shapes so it goes into like
this uh
hexagram and all these different shapes
yeah depending on what frequencies so if
you change the frequency the patterns
change right and so if it can do that
and that's why i was talking about
prayer and churches and singing there
was a time when a lot of humanity would
get together at least once a week and it
would sing together and it would pray
together and no matter who you're
praying to god or yahweh or the creator
or the maker whoever you want to pray to
if everybody's on the same frequency
everybody's on the same
energy and they're giving you all this
energy how could that be bad
look at this thing yeah this is some
weird [ __ ]
so the ultrasonic waves are causing
these objects to levitate so they're
levitating in the ultrasonic waves is
that ice i don't know because i don't
even think it says exactly what they're
floating there it's probably just a
piece of maybe like rice or a piece of
paper or something holy [ __ ] but i've
all people speculate this is maybe how
the the pyramids might have been made
because of the frequencies that people
think they make or could have made you
know back when they existed in the way
they did in their original form
and if you think about all of i don't
know how that this is part of like
something
stuff and eddie griffin said outside the
comedy store once high as [ __ ]
smoking cigarettes
pyramids were made with sound
yeah
there's a frequency i remember one of
someone's talked about there's a hum in
there there's a specific frequency in
one of the pyramids i don't remember ah
well there's some something certainly to
like the shape of the stone and the fact
that it's all gonna echo like crazy and
there's that one pyramid in south
america you can yell at it and it gives
you a bird sound back yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's something going on it's
weird i wonder mermaid culture that
sound have you ever seen that jamie
where the guy stands down to the bottom
of uh i think it's in chichen itza and
he makes some noise what did he do did
he yell i think you can make clap you
can make any noise loud noise that it
comes back as a bird it sounds weird
it's pretty cool and that's like the
temple of quetzalcoatl i think too i
might have made that up but that's like
their birthday sounded good they're
crazy uh bird god is it in chichen itza
uh chicha needs to echo clap but if you
do they do this
[Laughter]
if you saw how big this pyramid is and
how far away this guy is from it you
would realize how crazy that is if
you're listening to this just listening
to this this is a simple echo actually
it's very simple to explain when you
clap in front
of uh
i mean of a slope
the sound will go to to the top
in this case a pyramid
and if it's there a cavity or a
tempo like in this case the echo
will come back to you
if you clap in front of an egyptian
permit
nothing happens
because the sound goes away
but here
sound if they did that on purpose
imagine they figured that out on purpose
imagine if they designed that if they
designed that we need to figure out what
the [ __ ] went wrong like what happened
something happened there what is it the
driest
yeah younger driving track theory yeah
nobody talks about that why don't we
ever talk about the fact that we were
very advanced human beings doing amazing
things in pyramids and doing this and
floating rocks and doing space stuff
maybe back in those days and then it
always destroyed now we're rebuilding
why can't we accept that fact
well
you know
i think it's
civilization has these uh
rises and falls and we always want to
believe that we're in the middle of
rising and we're at the highest level
that people have ever been because we're
way higher than anybody that we know of
and when we look back a thousand years
from now yeah we're way more advanced
than them but when you take into account
the younger driest impact theory you've
got to get it gets real confusing
because
you start going well okay
if that did happen like how smart people
were people 12 000 years ago if if the
u.s
was really covered half of it was
covered in a mile-high sheet of ice
and
people were creating these insane
structures yeah like in saint whether
it's the pyramids of egypt or i mean i
don't know what year machu picchu was
made but a lot of people dated back a
long time ago as well i mean uh in that
is machu picchu from that era like when
do they think machu picchu was
constructed
but it's another one of those things it
just doesn't make it doesn't make any
sense it's so amazing if it makes sense
like how did you get these stones here
they're so big and it's so perfect and
beautiful and the way they contoured the
stones to fit into these slots it's
incredible
we still can't 1450 really that seems
wrong there's no way oh that might be
just one of those things there's one of
those things where like archaeologists
they'll date a thing
and you know you can't really date stone
so they date
whether it's uh biological material they
have to find like a piece of wood or
something something that they can do a
carbon dating something on you can't
date stones so they probably just kind
of guessing they might be off
and the thing is like that becomes
doctrine with a lot of people like you
know they found that thing uh gobekli
tepe and that threw a monkey wrench into
everything because for sure that's 12
000 years old
for sure so that means somebody covered
it up intentionally 12 000 years ago
that means they could build this stuff
12 000 years ago like how yeah how did
they how are they able to make these
immense stone columns when we think that
these people are supposed
that makes sense